technically i did my third year at
navarro 2021 but
because of covid it kind of threw
everything off and i technically do have
one more year of eligibility
there if navarro slips up this year
trinity valley is right there to snatch
the title from them how and when did you
guys find out that trinity valley would
be featured in season two and how did
you feel about that i honestly didn't
even know that they were filming at
trinity valley because i didn't know
this until literally like around covid i
think because a couple of my friends
they were on the valley and they're like
yeah netflix is coming over here too and
i was like oh really but it really
didn't make me feel any type of way just
because i know that they are athletes
also and i know they love what they do
also and i do have some friends on
trinity valley and i do like i cheer
with some of them right now we all just
want the same thing we all have a
passion for the sport and we all love it
and yeah we as much as i say like oh
yeah we're friends like the minute that
we get on the mat that's a different
story that competitive side is gonna
come out and you're gonna be ready to go
but overall like i think that they are
also a great program and it is always
been a neck and neck thing with navarro
and tvcc but overall have a lot of
respect for them what was that moment
like after having been through cove and
shutting down and then finally competing
in 2021
and then
you lose
it was definitely like i was so ready
for 2020 i was like
we're going like we're doing this we are
right there and we're gonna go and like
you know defend our title
and when covet happened it was kind of
just like a
dang like we worked
all this time to basically come to the
very very last part and it wasn't even
like we had the option to do it or not
it was kind of just like you're not
doing it anymore like it's done and i
think it really was an eye-opener for
like just you never know what can happen
things can happen all the time and it's
just it makes you really appreciate the
people more so i think 2021 like we
really like overall appreciated each
other a lot more even though we may not
have always seen eye to eye with each
other and we may have fought with each
other like we loved each other very very
much
navarro and trinity valley
battling it out yet again
there's a little bit of talk in the
episodes about the fame that navarro has
had and how are the judges gonna score
now do they want the underdog to win did
you feel that the scoring was fair or
were you frustrated i mean honestly i
think that
we did we had a mistake and mistakes
happen and it is a part of this sport
it's a part of any sport you're not
always going to be perfect but i don't
think that because monica necessarily
wasn't around as much that that's why
that mistake happened because personally
we hit so many times before
that one mistake and honestly it's a
part of cheerleading and i think that no
matter what like whether monica was
there all year where she wasn't i think
mistakes happen and it is not in
monica's control it's in our control and
i know that dancing with the stars was a
very big thing for her and i think that
overall like her going it's not like we
were by ourselves like we had andy and
we also had kaylee and i think that
kaylee like specifically did a really
good job and like i personally felt like
kaylee was handling it very very well
and honestly like our routine in daytona
like it was one of the best routines
even with the outcomes like i felt like
it was a very very well put together
routine and i felt like we were as
prepared as we could have been i gave
everything i had into that season and
into that performance in daytona i
definitely don't regret anything and you
know mistakes happen and it's a part of
being an athlete like you're gonna have
your great moments and you're gonna have
your hits
and successes but you're also going to
have your
setbacks and you're going to have your
falls and i think that
specifically for this year like monica
is coming in hard because obviously
behind every failure
comes a comeback and it comes back even
harder i don't need to win any more
trophies but i do want to be the best
well where will we see you go from here
are you done at navarro or could you
come back again i don't totally know all
the rules and regulations technically i
did my third year at navarro 2021 but
because of covid it kind of threw
everything off and i technically do have
one more year of eligibility there hey
gabby butler season three of cheer
i don't know we'll see
but i am still cheering and i
uh going into this second semester i
have had a lot of obstacles still thrown
at me that a lot of people don't know
about so i am not sure but just stay
tuned is that anything you want to share
or we'll be sharing soon just yeah just
stay tuned whatever i'm going to do it's
going to be it's going to be the best
decision and what really is just going
to make me the happiest so yeah gabby
are you going to trinity valley
oh no no girl no yeah i am
a navarro
a rider died for the rest of my life
yeah well respect them but yeah no is
season three a possibility for you or is
it totally ruled out
uh
i don't know honestly i'm just kind of
playing it day by day trying to figure
out what my life
is going on so we will see could we ever
see you coach at navarro or coach
anywhere so i have been told a bunch of
times that i would be a great coach and
honestly it's not something that i've
really always liked dreamt of but i feel
like it is something that i would be
very good at just because of all the
things that i've learned over the past
years from all these different coaches i
have so much knowledge and i do have a
lot of love for this sport so i do think
it might be something that i would
consider yes one day
yes maybe one day yeah so will we see
you at daytona in 2022
most yes
most likely yes